merci beaucoup pour cette introduction
et et merci de de m'accueillir pour
échanger avec vous à propos de l'Inde
effectivement sachant que le Pakistan
est aussi un domaine d'études comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le Président et
que on ne peut pas parler de l'incend
évoquer l'autre dans bien des dans bien
des cas ce que je vais essayer de faire
en
pour introduire notre conversation c'est
de
d'observer les les deux évolutions que
vous avez d'ailleurs déjà évoqué en
termes de politique étrangère l'Inde a
beaucoup évolué je me rappelle avoir
participé à la visite de Jacques Chirac
en janvier 98 lorsque le partenariat
stratégique entre la France et l'Inde
avait été nouée on était au tout début
d'une relation qui depuis n'a cessé de
se resserrer et l'Inde a au cours de ces
dernières décennies
des évolutions par lesquelles je
commencerai et puis deuxième partie
c'est un plan à la Science Po
la politique intérieure qui
effectivement
évolue elle aussi et évolue dans une
direction qui peut nous inquiéter et
la tend d'ailleurs en termes de
traitement des minorités qu'en termes de
réduction des libertés alors d'abord
cette
évolution à l'international c'est-à-dire
que l'Inde est devenu
un pays central pour notre politique en
Indo-Pacifique et d'ailleurs vous avez à
l'écran la carte que nous avons
construite à Sciences Po nous avons créé
un observatoire franco-allemande de
l'Indo pacifique avec des partenaires
de l'Institut de Hambourg le Guigard et
vous avez une carte qui vous montre
l'ampleur voilà de la vision que la
France a de l'Indo-Pacifique et la carte
précédente vous montrait à peu près les
mêmes frontières la France et l'Inde
sont les seuls pays à avoir une vision
aussi inclusive de ce qu'elle
Indo-Pacifique ça va de la côte Est de
l'Afrique à la côte ouest des États-Unis
aucun autre pays nous avons fait 12
cartes sur ce site internet montrant les
visions de l'Indo pacifique de 12 pays
aucun autre pays n'a une vision aussi
extensive c'est un des points que nous
avons en commun mais
ce n'est évidemment pas suffisant pour
faire un partenariat et ce que je
voudrais dire pour commencer c'est que
ce que l'on a vu au cours des dernières
années c'est un rapprochement non pas
seulement de l'Inde et de la France mais
de l'un des deux l'Occident et ceci
s'est trouvé un peu accéléré et même
beaucoup accéléré par les pressions
chinoises et sur le petit diaposit sur
le petit diaporama que nous ont préparé
si vous remontez au début de la série de
cartes vous enverrai une montrant les
incursions croissantes de la Chine
enzonimalayenne on en parle assez peu on
en a parlé en 2020 lorsque
voilà à cet endroit là au Tibet enfin au
Ladak qui est la zone frontalière du
Tibet et bien l'armée chinoise a mené
une offensive dans la vallée de la
galwan qui s'est traduite par la mort de
20 soldats indiens jamais encore depuis
1967 les échanges de tir et pas que de
tirs d'ailleurs et pas principalement de
tir de quoi c'est du corps à corps qu'il
s'agit en fait on est à des altitudes
telles que qui font que lorsqu'un soldat
est frappé blessé tombe dans une rivière
et bien il meurt et ainsi que les vins
soldats indiens sont morts et jamais
depuis 37 on avait eu un bilan aussi
lourd
alors cette pression chinoise je prends
cet exemple on pourrait en trouver
d'autres elle joue un rôle très
important dans la façon dont l'un ne se
tourne vers l'Occident et c'est à la
suite d'ailleurs de cette
de cet échange de de cette de ce clash
je cherche le mot français mais il ne me
revient pas que l'Inde a accepté de
faire que le quad soit élevé au niveau
ministériel le quad c'est le symbole de
se rapprochement de l'Inde et de
l'Occident et de l'Inde et des
États-Unis en particulier dans
l'Indopacifique car jusque là les
Indiens avaient souhaité ne jamais voir
des puissances étrangères dans leur
marée Nostrum dans leur Océan Indien et
là la puissance la pression chinoise
est-elle que on est plus que demandeur
de partenariat avec des Occidentaux à
commencer par les
Américains et les Australiens pour
résister c'est le premier changement
absolument remarquable qui nous amène à
comparer un contrasté la position
actuelle de la position par exemple
d'Indira Gandhi qui lorsque les
Américains avaient mis un pied à Diego
Garcia avec poussé léocris à l'époque
dans les 70 il n'était pas question que
les Américains viennent dans l'océan
Indien aujourd'hui on les invite on les
appelle et on veut faire le maximum de
choses avec eux avec eux et avec la
France et ici si bien sûr de la France
qu'il faut plutôt parler s'il y a un
rapprochement avec une puissance
européenne
aujourd'hui du point de vue indien du
côté indien c'est la France la France du
fait de ce partenariat stratégique bien
sûr qui est très fort mais du fait aussi
des échanges que vous avez évoqués en
introduction et principalement des
achats d'armes la France est devenue
l'un le tout premier fournisseur d'armes
de l'Inde il y avait déjà un
héritage rappelons-nous les mirages la
visite de François Mitterrand 1982 c'est
le début c'est le début de
vente d'armes de plus en plus
importantes les scorpen et puis
maintenant les rafales donc on a une
montée en puissance de ce partenariat on
peut le dire stratégique et militaire
qui se traduit aussi d'ailleurs par
des accès mutuels
réciproque à des bases militaires la
visite de Emmanuel Macron en mars 2018 a
permis que les Indiens puissent accéder
à des bases militaires françaises dans
l'océan Indien notamment à la réunion
avec une réciprocité et puis il y a bien
sûr aussi les manœuvres conjointe les
manœuvres Varuna par exemple qui sont
très anciennes et qui permettent à des
appareils à des à des navires français
et indiens de tester leur
interopérabilité le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle lui-même
est allé dans la zone pour l'une de ces
opérations de
l'exercice si vous préférez et un autre
point important
que l'on ne saurait négliger les
garde-côtes indiens font avec les
garde-côtes français des patrouilles
c'est les seuls qui ne soient pas de la
région qui sont ainsi invités à ce genre
de manœuvre mais c'est que la France
aide la région puisque la France est
puissance résidente de l'océan Indien et
que
l'Inde le reconnaît est considère que
c'est une bonne façon de travailler
ensemble
voilà quelques éléments
succincts mais j'espère assez
significatif qui illustre le
rapprochement de l'Inde et des
occidentaux les Américains bien sûr les
français aussi
maintenant en parallèle il y a une
continuité avec la politique antérieure
qu'on a qualifié de non alignement
et le non-alignement indien et bien il
se traduit aujourd'hui par le fait de ne
pas prendre parti
dans le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
alors c'est un positionnement très
ancien qui remonte à la prière puisque
Jawala le nérou Premier ministre de
l'Inde de 47 à 64 avec posé les bases de
cette
attitude refus de prendre parti pour un
bloc ou pour l'autre à l'époque c'était
bien sûr la guerre froide et il y voyait
une violence insupportable ça avait créé
un mouvement le mouvement des Non
Alignés dont la culture est quand même
très
résiliente et on le voit dans le
Canadien mais on pourrait et je suis
prêt à revenir à la discussion on la
voit dans le cas indonésien cette
culture aussi et j'étais à Jakarta l'été
dernier pour constater que les
différences entre ces deux pays
n'étaient pas si grandes
alors on voit quoi on voit
essentiellement un refus de prendre
parti dans les instances multilatérales
contre la Russie
l'absence de condamnation de l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine
abstention quasi systématique au
concepté ou l'Inde a été membre non
permanent jusqu'en décembre dernier
abstention quasi systématique à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
lorsque la question ukrainienne est
posée et parfois elle est posée pour des
raisons humanitaires et ça ne change
rien d'Inde ne se prononce pas ne se
prononce pas contre la Russie ou pour
l'Occident comment expliquer cela et ça
je crois que c'est vraiment la culture
internationale de l'Inde là qui est à
scruter de près il y a bien sûr un
élément
concret la dépendance militaire de
l'Inde vis-à-vis de la Russie
deux tiers des armements indiens sont
d'origine soviétique ou russe
et il y a bien sûr là
une corde de rappel une hypothèque qui
pèse toujours sur la liberté de parole
et d'attitude des Indiens et c'est
davantage vrai pour l'armée de terre que
pour
la marine mais c'est aussi très vrai
pour l'armée de l'air vous avez certes
des rafales et des mirages mais
énormément de soukoys et puis encore des
Migs
les Russes ont eu cette intelligence de
ne pas vendre trop cher parfois on peut
penser qu'il y a eu du dumping et
surtout de faire de la du
co-développement tu as du transfert de
technologie les Indiens sont très
demandeurs parce qu'ils n'ont toujours
pas d'industrie de défense de transe à
la technologie et et là les Russes sont
su faire de la coproduction et pas
seulement d'ailleurs dans les appareils
que je viens de citer c'est les Indiens
et les Russes qui ont développé un
missile à courte portée le brame que
maintenant l'un de la Russie vendent aux
Philippines par exemple donc on est sur
du co-développement de technologie
militaire l'Inde en veut davantage
encore encore une fois je le rappelle
mais c'est très important voilà un pays
qui n'a pas d'industrie de défense
et non pas réussi à construire
l'industrie de défense ils ont besoin de
l'aide internationale extérieure plutôt
pour pour cela et les Russes ont su être
je le répète moins 10 ans et
généreux en transat technologies mais ce
n'est pas la seule explication de
l'attitude indienne vis-à-vis de la
Russie dire que quand on lit les écrits
du ministre indien des Affaires
étrangère et Shankar qui est vraiment en
charge de la diplomatie indienne j'ai
Shankar parle au nom de l'état indien et
au nom du gouvernement indien avec toute
la légitimité qu'il faut lui reconnaître
et lorsqu'on le lit et bien on constate
qu'il y a qu'il y a deux autres raisons
pour lesquelles
l'un de ne condamne pas la Russie
d'abord
un antioxydantaliste
hérité de l'anti impérialiste on est en
situation post coloniale on n'est pas la
sortie d'un état d'esprit qui est
l'héritage de la lutte anti coloniale et
l'anti impérialisme et le mot d'ordre
c'est quelque chose qui en particulier
s'adresse aux Américains mais que tous
les Occidentaux
ont en partage première explication
deuxième explication est peut-être
est-elle plus importante encore une
vision du monde que j'ai sans car
qualifie de plurilatéral c'est quoi le
plurilatéralisme le plurilatéralisme
c'est ni le multilatéralisme ni le
bilatéralisme ni le nilatéralisme bien
sûr c'est la capacité de l'Inde de faire
avec des partenaires différents des
choses
qui soit distinctes les unes des autres
on choisit de faire telle opération avec
tel partenaire et puis tel autre
opération avec telle autre partenaire et
plus il y a de partenaires possibles
potentiel dans le jeu plus on a les
mains libres plus on a une marge de
manœuvre grande ça veut dire quoi dire
qu'on ne se lie jamais les mains avec un
allié l'idée d'alliance d'ailleurs est
banni de l'Inde on n'a pas d'allier en
Inde on cherche des partenaires mais
pour des opérations qui seront
ponctuelles de manière à avoir le la
plus grande marge de manœuvre possible
et dans ce cadre dans cette dans cette
vision
plurilatérale du monde et bien plus il y
a de pôles plus il y a de partenaires
possibles mieux ça vaut et pour cela
l'un veut une Russie forte elle veut une
Russie forte
parce qu'elle dépend de la Russie pour
ses armements mais elle veut une Russie
forte pour élargir le champ des
possibles de même qu'elle veut une Union
européenne forte une Union européenne
forte c'est aussi important pour l'Inde
parce que ça fait un pôle de puissance
en plus dans le jeu ce qu'elle redoute
le plus c'est le monde bipolaire et
manque de chance
c'est la combat c'est dans cette
direction que que le monde est parti et
c'est une des grandes hypothèques qui
pèsent sur la politique étrangère de
l'Inde c'est-à-dire que elle se trouve
en un sens courtisé par tous
on l'a vu récemment il y a eu un grand
ballet diplomatique suite à l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie tous les pays
ont envoyé des émissaires pour essayer
d'amener l'Inde de leur côté mais comme
elle n'est venue d'aucun côté elle peut
ne pas être seulement courtisée par tous
mais finalement isolé et ne sachant pas
comment gérer la bipolarisation
croissance du monde il y a là un défi
que on va d'ailleurs voir se répéter
au G20 du mois de septembre le G20 du
mois dernier des ministres étrangères a
montré les limites de de l'exercice
d'équilibrisme que l'un d'essayer de
mener de faire un consensus sur la
question ukrainienne ça a échoué Russie
et Chine on fait dérailler cette
initiative ils vont remettre
le couvert ces choses dire en septembre
rien ne dit que ça marchera si
véritablement il y a un une
division des puissances internationales
autour de deux ensembles
et sont plurilatéralisme vont avoir des
difficultés de positionnement et là il y
a un défi qui est majeur donc voilà ce
que je pouvais dire sur les questions
internationales et sur la politique
étrangère de l'Inde de manière brève
mais j'espère suffisamment clair
la situation
intérieure
je vais essayer de m'y attarder
davantage parce que je pense que il y a
là pour nous des interrogations qui
doivent faire débat
on a un lien de plus en plus fort avec
ce pays sont toujours savoir où il va et
mieux cerner sa trajectoire
intérieure me paraît vraiment capital
vous l'avez dit en introduction ligne
d'audva le nationalisme indou est
maintenant au pouvoir depuis 2014 et
cela se traduit par une forme de
marginalisation des minorités du pays de
plus en plus préoccupantes
aux années 20 de toute façon
un siècle plus tard nous sommes de
retour aux années 20
les années d'entre-deux-guerres ou se
sont cristallisés tellement de
nationalisme
exacerbées c'est une illogie qui
consiste à dire l'Inde est hindou à 80%,
les hindous sont les fils du sol sont la
population autochtone les minorités les
musulmans les chrétiens en particulier
sont des pièces rapportées qui ne
peuvent pas prétendre à un statut de
citoyenneté
donc on crée des citoyens de seconde
zone et les musulmans sont les
principales victimes de cette tendance
qui est à la fois de fait et de droit de
fait parce que le mouvement de
nationaliste un doux est très puissant
sur le terrain c'est un mouvement qui
remonte à 1925 c'est un des plus anciens
mouvements
de ce type au monde c'est comme si les
différentes chemises de différentes
couleurs qui se sont développées dans
l'entre-deux-guerres en France elle est
continuer à prospérer vous vous souvenez
sans doute que dans les années 20 il y
avait des chemises vertes des chemises
brunes des chemises de tout feu les
couleurs et bien ce mouvement il a il a
une chemise blanche il a un calot noir
il a un short kaki il a des boots et
puis une arme une arme blanche ça c'est
l'uniforme de ce mouvement ce mouvement
est très puissant sur le terrain car
depuis un siècle il a C é de pénétrer la
société alors société très diverses
territoires très étendu nous parlons
d'un territoire qui fait la taille de
l'Union européenne 3 millions 200000
km². et néanmoins ils ont pratiquement
implanter leur présence développer leur
présence partout sauf dans l'extrême sud
et
on les a vu développer un syndicat
étudiant à syndicat ouvrier un syndicat
paysan ils sont dans toutes les
catégories de la société avec ce même
discours que celui que j'ai présenté en
introduction
donc sur le terrain ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile pour les musulmans de
pratiquer leur religion pour les
chrétiens de pratiquer leur religion
des églises sont attaquées une liste de
la croix est en train de faire un
reportage qui va sortir pour le pour le
week-end de Pâques et je vous recommande
sa lecture car ce sera du terrain
détaillé
et les musulmans sont la cible
principale de sorte que
les milices les groupes paramilitaires
qui patrouille les campus universitaires
qui patrouillent même les villes
empêchent des musulmans par exemple
d'acquérir un logement dans des
quartiers mixtes la ghettoïsation des
musulmans est l'un des est l'une des
conséquences de ce processus et alors
quand j'ai des ghettoïsation je ne parle
pas simplement du fait que les pauvres
se retrouvent ensemble un ghetto au
contraire par définition on le
au point d'ailleurs que Mark Zuckerberg
s'est émue de l'usage qui a été fait de
Twitter ce qui est rare
deux jurer des yurets et bien on a des
lois des lois aussi qui mettent le
sécularisme indien a rude épreuve l'un
des sinon laïque du moins séculière ça
veut dire que toutes les religions sont
reconnues sur un pied d'égalité dans la
Constitution
mais on voit pour la première fois des
lois qui donnent un hindouisme une
primauté
un exemple le
Citizen ship Act la loi définissant la
citoyenneté en Inde a été amendée en
2019 de sorte que seuls les non
musulmans
issus du Bangladesh de l'Afghanistan ou
du Pakistan sont maintenant éligibles à
la citoyenneté indienne
ce qui est en contradiction directe avec
la
lettre et l'esprit de la Constitution du
pays autre exemple au même moment où
presque le l'article 370 de la caution
indienne qui donnait au Japon et
cachemire une autonomie particulière a
été abolie et le Jamo est cachemire le
jambon cachemire qui était un État de
l'Union indienne a été rétrogradée au
statut de théâtre de l'Union et le Ladak
a été coupé a été séparée et devenu un
territoire de l'Union aussi
à ce moment là ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la police de l'État est
maintenant directement responsable
devant New Delhi et non plus devant le
gouvernement de la région c'est un effet
de centralisation et de fait le jeune
week Kashmir est sous administration
directe de New Delhi depuis 2019
trois anciens chefs du gouvernement de
cet état ont été emprisonnés pendant
plusieurs mois et les élections sont
reportées
de loin en loin
ça c'est l'aspect je dirais purement
ethnique ethnou religieux qui fait que
la démocratie
est mise à mal du point de vue du
multiculturalisme qui était la grande
tradition indienne rappelons-nous le
matmagandi qui était toujours prêt à
défendre les minorités quand elles
étaient attaquées maintenant la
démocratie elle est aussi
mise en difficulté
du point de vue de ce que nous appelons
la tendance à l'île libéralisme
cette idée de démocratie libérale me met
toujours mal à l'aise parce que c'est
une contradiction dans les termes et je
préfère parler d'autoritarisme
électorale on a un système
où les élections continuent à être le
mode de désignation du
chef du gouvernement
des responsables
mais entre les élections on a des
tendances autoritaires qui finalement
rendent l'élection
pratiquement redondantes parce que il
n'y a pas la compétition politique qui
permet que les élections soient libres
et entièrement fiable que se passe-t-il
entre les élections les institutions de
l'État ont été
d'assaut par le parti au pouvoir et
la liste est longue je me contenterai de
mentionner deux ou trois institutions
le central de rock investigation le FBI
indien et maintenant un bras armé du
pouvoir et d'un pouvoir partisan la
commission électorale la commission
électorale qui est censée organiser les
scrutins de manière impartiale est elle
aussi peuplée d'amis du pouvoir
plus important le pouvoir judiciaire
partout dans ces pays et je mets l'un de
maintenant quasiment dans la même
catégorie que la Hongrie de Orban la
Pologne de kashinski
Israël aujourd'hui partout le pouvoir
judiciaire et la cible privilégié et ce
que Netanyahu cherche à faire
aujourd'hui et bien maudit à essayer de
le faire dès qu'il a pris le pouvoir en
2014 la première loi qu'il a fait passer
le premier amendement à la Constitution
qu'il a fait voter a consisté à changer
la façon dont les juges la Cour suprême
allait être nommé c'est toujours la même
chose
la Cour suprême était nommée elle était
encore d'ailleurs je vais vous dire en
quoi par d'autres juges les juges se
coop en quelque sorte et les juges des
tribunaux des états désigne les juges de
la Cour suprême la loi le changement qui
a été prévu par cette réforme avec pour
objectif de remettre la nomination des
juges à 5 personnes seulement dont 3
responsables politiques il n'y avait
plus que deux magistrats dans le comité
chargé de désigner les juges de la Cour
suprême la Cour suprême a mis un pied à
la porte et empêcher que cette loi passe
mais le grand évangé en refusant
désormais de nommer les juges que le
collège des magistrats désignaient pour
occuper le poste de membre de la Cour
suprême de sorte que en 2015 2016-2017
on a eu un nombre de juges partis à la
retraite et non remplacé qui a créé une
vraie crise et en 2017 la Cour suprême
s'est résignée à ne pas chercher à
nommer des membres nouveaux qui
n'auraient pas la bénédiction du pouvoir
et donc on est dans une situation
d'auto-censure de la Cour suprême depuis
maintenant plusieurs années et
aujourd'hui même d'ailleurs un test
intéressant va avoir lieu puisque Raoul
Gandhi a été disqualifié je vais reviens
dans un instant et la Cour suprême va
devoir dire si disqualifier le leader de
l'opposition qui Raoul Gandhi dans les
conditions actuelles c'est véritablement
légal sera-t-elle irathel toujours la
même direction de docilité vis-à-vis du
pouvoir
ou pas c'est un des grands des gros
enjeux mais ça amène au troisième point
que je voulais mentionner l'opposition
à une tâche de plus en plus ardu en Inde
de très nombreux hommes politiques ont
été disqualifiés empêché de se présenter
aux élections
arrêter
et puis on bénéficié de la visite de
d'agents venus contrôler leur
déclaration d'impôts ou autres et toutes
sortes de
raisons les ont mis hors d'état de nuire
c'est nouveau Raoul Gandhi le leader du
principal parti d'opposition et dans la
même situation aujourd'hui puisqu'il a
été condamné à deux ans de prison
et que deux ans de prison ça l'oblige à
démissionner de son mandat de député
donc il est exclu du Parlement est-ce
que tu Parlement parce que dans le au
Parlement Raoul Gandhi était là voir qui
était la plus étonnante
dissonante en tout cas et on a donc un
parti d'opposition le Congrès qui est
privé de son leader en tout cas dans
l'enceinte parlementaire et c'est une
atteinte évidemment claire au jeu
démocratique
j'en cite deux autres pour compléter ce
tableau on a des restrictions à l'action
de la presse qui sont de plus en plus
fortes et si vous regardez les
classements quel que soit les
classements vous regardez Freedom House
voire des reporters en France frontières
tous les classements concernant la
liberté d'expression en Inde font
dégringoler le pays dans les vers la fin
de la liste
une des raisons étant que vous avez de
plus en plus la prise de contrôle de
médias indépendants par des hommes
d'affaires proche du pouvoir là on
retrouve le modèle Orban d'ailleurs
exactement
copier-coller toute façon bon c'est une
des choses à laquelle on travaille en ce
moment à Sciences Po c'est les
communications
internes ou externe d'ailleurs entre ces
personnalités qui en fait échangent les
bonnes pratiques et bénéficient de de
conseils de de marketeurs certains
d'ailleurs basé aux États-Unis on a
découvert que ABCO worldware conseillait
beaucoup de ces personnes pendant cité
qu'une alors la presse les médias
notamment la télévision ont été
tellement
mise en difficulté que par exemple le
grand mouvement que Raoul Gandhi a animé
ces derniers mois une marche de 3500 km
de la pointe sud de l'Inde jusque au
Japon et cachemire à à peine été
couverte dans dans les médias dernier
dernier point
parmi les
dissidents potentiels
vous avez évidemment les ONG et les
intellectuels et dans les deux cas on
les voit victime de politique très
ciblées les ONG en particulier alors de
toutes sortes il y a les ONG
confessionnelles bien sûr les ONG
chrétiennes qui ont tout de suite été
ciblées et ont perdu l'accès aux
ressources étrangères et puis il y a les
ONG
qui sont plus de droits de l'Homme
Amnesty International
deux exemples amis ne peut plus
fonctionner en Inde
a été empêché de continuer son activité
en Inde campusen une ONG chrétienne qui
depuis 1968 travaillait en Inde à
l'éducation des enfants et 140000
enfants
de toutes les religions profiter de
cette de ces de leur activité
ces deux organes bien d'autres ont perdu
l'accès au fond étranger et n'étant plus
en mesure de collecter des fonds à
l'étranger elles ont mis la clé sous la
porte on est passé de 30000 ONG à une
dizaine de milliers d'ONG aujourd'hui en
quelques années deux tiers de ONG
indiennes ont dû renoncer leur travail
alors que l'un des temps pays de NG s'il
y a bien un pays où ce sont les ONG qui
s'occupent des soins de l'éducation
c'est l'Inde et là on a un vraiment qui
a gagné
les intellectuels c'est d'abord les
universitaires les universités indiennes
ont été pour la plupart
mise en difficulté par la nomination de
nouveaux présidents la grande université
de Delhi Nero University et premier
exemple mais il y en a bien d'autres et
même les universités privées
l'Universités privées qui
pour nous était des partenaires et là je
parle au nom de Sciences Po on avait
quantité de partenaires dans le monde de
l'université privée et bien celle-ci
perdent aussi leur liberté d'expression
et rendre la collaboration très
difficile donc voilà un défi qui pour
nous je crois mérite réflexion nous
sommes devenus un partenaire stratégique
important d'un pays dont la trajectoire
politique intérieure n'est pas
nécessairement celle que nous attendions
et celles sur laquelle nous avions fondé
nos premières actions
je conclus par l’économie parce que
effectivement et les graphiques que vous
avez vu défiler
le montrait il y a de grands espoirs mis
dans l'économie indienne d'abord du fait
ça démographie effectivement on a
maintenant avec l'Inde le premier pays
au monde en termes démographique et la
croissance démographique va sans doute
se poursuivre jusqu'à 2050 on travaille
l'instrumental il y a des projections en
ce moment pour essayer justement de
faire de la prospective sur l'Inde et on
se dit que probablement 2050 sera le pic
ça peut être plus tard 2060 ça veut dire
que l'Inde à un énorme potentiel en si
en termes de dividendes démographique
vous savez ce qu'on appelle une vente
démographique c'est les 15 49 ans par
rapport aux autres quand la catégorie
des personnes en âge de travailler et
bien supérieur à la
aux autres catégories qui ne sont pas un
âge de travailler alors on bénéficie
d'un dividende démographique
quelque chose qui évidemment mérite
d'être
traité quand on parle de divan
démographique à côté de ça il y a des
fleurons dans cette économie qui reste
les moteurs de la croissance une
croissance vive vigoureuse et évidemment
c'est le secteur du it des technologies
de l'informatique qui sont les
principaux moteurs l'adresse absolument
imbattable dans ce domaine avec de très
belles entreprises
tata consultant si service Infosys 8 Pro
qui sont des leaders mondiaux qui
continuent à caracoler en tête du CAC 40
à l'indienne le point noir c'est
l'industrie l'industrie ne cesse de
perdre des parts de
départ de marché
et ne représente plus guère que 15% du
PNB
c'est un pays qui du coup donne à son
à son profil économique des allures
postes industrielles avant d'avoir été
industriel
c'est les services qui comme dans toutes
les postes
sont majoritaires mais là n'a pas
industrialisé sa société encore et du
coup il y a là un défi que
n'a rien de drama maudit pensait relever
en attirant des investisseurs étrangers
en faisant que ce soit des
multinationales qui viennent
industrialiser l'Inde c'est son grand
programme make India qui comme un des
graphiques qui figurait sur le
powerpoint le montre ses investissements
étrangers n'ont pas eu lieu
deux points pour conclure sur l'économie
ce que
l'économie politique de l'un nous montre
c'est une évolution vers un système
oligopolistique et ça c'est lié encore
une fois au régime dont on parle les
oligarques les oligarques indiens sont
les grands bénéficiaires du nouveau
du nouveau régime l'un d'entre eux
goutamadani est devenu en quelques
années l'homme le plus riche de l'Inde
et ceci grâce aux privatisation
notamment puisque les privatisations
d'aéroports de port lyon-permis
d'acquérir grâce à ses amitiés
politiques des grandes des grands
fleurons des infrastructures indiennes
cela un inconvénient
parce que c'est aux dépens du rôle des
régulateurs et tout récemment il y a
quelques semaines
euh gothamadani a été accusé de mal
versation et son cours de Bourse a chuté
dramatiquement montrant la fragilité de
ce genre de fonctionnement c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles la olgandi
est personne Greta au Parlement il était
celui qui systématiquement annoncé les
méthodes de gothamadani l'autre
inconvénient de ce système oligarchique
c'est que il a tendance à fermer le jeu
et les entreprises étrangères ne sont
pas bienvenus car sont les compétiteurs
qu'on redoute ces grands hommes
d'affaires
Vodafone on a fait les frais Walmart on
a fait les frais ce sont des des des
grandes entreprises
reliant par exemple qui ne veulent pas
voir arriver de compétiteur et qui du
coup
invente ou trouve les moyens de créer
des barrières non tarifaires alors les
bailleurs tarifaires sont déjà assez
élevés mais les barrières non tarifaires
c'est encore plus redoutable parce que
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas lutter
avec avec les
dominants locaux et j'aimerais là dessus
le protectionnisme est sans doute l'un
des autres problèmes qu'il nous faut
gérer surtout à l'heure où le ou le ou
le
traité de libre-échange avec l'Union
européenne est en discussion il y a deux
ans ou presque on a relancé la
négociation sur ce traité de
libre-échange la négociation avait duré
de 2000 à 2013 et elle n'avait pas
abouti on a relancé la négociation sur
un traité de libre-échange Union
européenne 1 et les difficultés que l'on
rencontre soient un peu les mêmes que
dans les années 2010 quand on cherchait
encore à faire à faire
le protectionnisme indien
est très et très fort et et de plus en
plus fort de plus en plus fort
sachant que par ailleurs ce qu'il
demande à l'Union européenne est aussi
de moins en moins acceptable par nous
des visas des visas pour des ingénieurs
pour des aromaticiens notamment donc on
a on a nous côté européen aussi des
formes de protectionnisme qui se sont
développées mais sur le terrain indien
c'est une des grandes difficultés
et je terminerai par là
concerne la protection des données
personnelles aujourd'hui quand on fait
du commerce international le
e-commerce notamment implique que les
données personnelles bénéficient de
certaines protection l'un ne veut pas se
doter d'une loi qui ressemble peu au
pros à la rgpd il n'y a pas de loi
protégeant les données personnelles elle
préfère pouvoir garder l'accès à ces
données
et cela va compliquer singulièrement la
conclusion de certains aspects de ce
traité de libre-échange ce n'est pas du
protectionnisme là c'est une forme de
implication économique d'une tendance
politique la surveillance des citoyens
doit permettre l'accès aux données
personnelles protéger des personnels
n'est pas l'ordre du jour en Inde
aujourd'hui
nous avons d'ailleurs à la demande de
l'AFD organisée les 12 et 13 juin
prochain à Sciences Po toute une journée
sur ces questions de
Digital India qu'est-ce que une
indigitale sans protection des données
personnelles et qu'est-ce que ça
implique pour nos collaborations
notamment au plan économique donc ça
c'est un autre des aspects que on doit
situer au croisement du politique et de
l'économie en vérité voilà je m'arrête
là merci
le directeur merci beaucoup pour
cette exposé à la fois exhaustif précis
parce que non je trouve et inquiétant je
le crois aussi sur ce fantastique pays
qui nous réserve
probablement des surprises voire des
désillusions l'avenir le dira j'ai
plusieurs collègues qui souhaitent vous
poser des questions ce que j'en ai 6 ou
7 ce que je vous propose c'est de les
prendre et puis vous aurez ensuite le
temps nécessaire pour y répondre la
première question c'est Joël guerriot
qui la pose votre voisin merci président
il y a quelques années en 2020 nous
étions avec huxory et puis Rachid temal
dans un groupe qui travaillait sur leur
un rapport sur l'Inde qui a été publié
en juillet 2020 et qui porte le titre
l'Inde un partenaire un partenaire
stratégique
donc nous sommes nous étions dans cette
conviction et malheureusement nous avons
été privés du fait de la pandémie de
nous rendre en Inde et de voir plutôt
que d'entendre
mais déjà nous avions fait un travail
qui nous avait permis de mesurer à quel
point ce sujet est majeur pour l'avenir
je dirais même de notre planète le égard
l'importance de l'Inde et j'aurais
revenir sur un point que vous avez
évoqué que la population de l'Inde à
savoir aujourd'hui un milliard 400
millions de personnes avec une évolution
comme vous l'avez dit avec un pic qui
serait attendu en 2050 qui serait entre
1 milliard 600000 Lyon à 1 milliard 700
millions donc ça veut dire une
population très très importante et
j'aurais parce que vous avez eu un
exposé très très intéressant où vous
nous avez vous avez touché du doigt
beaucoup de sujets je sais combien c'est
difficile de parler de tout puisque il
s'agit là d'un très grand pays mais pour
autant on n'a pas parlé de la population
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce point à
deux niveaux le premier c'est sur le
plan de la pauvreté parce que si l'un
des pays aussi important en nombre c'est
aussi un pays qui a le plus nombreux le
plus grand nombre de pauvres alors
qu'elle peut qu'elle avenir attendre sur
ce pays à travers est-ce qu'il y a une
lutte contre la pauvreté est-ce que on
peut espérer qu'un jour les choses
aillent mieux pour cette population
extrêmement
mise à l'écart et les conséquences que
ce même cela pourrait avoir en termes de
révolte de réaction par rapport à cette
situation et surtout si vous vous
évoquez le fait maintenant que les
oligarques que accumulent des fortunes
alors même que il y a dans ce pays
beaucoup pas faire par rapport à ces
personnes en difficulté et dans le même
ordre d'idée je voudrais quand on parle
de population humaine aujourd'hui on a
aussi toujours une inquiétude c'est le
changement climatique et les
conséquences sur le changement
climatique par rapport à des
comportements qui sont des comportements
évidemment peu propices à l'avenir de
notre planète alors je voudrais savoir
si il y a des partenariats que l'on
pourra attendre sur le plan énergétique
sur le plan de développement durable sur
le plan environnemental entre la France
et puis l'Inde sur cet aspect est-ce que
vous pourriez nous en dire plus eu égard
également au fait que nous pensons bien
sûr que c'est là un sujet majeur qu'il
ne faut pas sous-estimer par rapport à
tout ce qui s'est passé au travers des
relations internationales vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de pluralisme
est-ce que c'est dans le pluralisme anax
sur lequel la France pourrait être le
premier partenaire merci
merci Joël François Bonnot maintenant
qui a la parole merci président
merci également pour votre exposé qui
était particulièrement intéressante et
passionnant
dans la compétition qu'on peut voir
entre l'Inde et la Chine notamment et
que vous avez évoqué il y a
effectivement des choses qui jouent en
faveur de l'Inde et d'autres pas et
j'aimerais vous poser une question par
rapport au système des castes en Inde et
si vous pouvez me dire aujourd'hui ce
que ça peut représenter comme comme
frein pour le pôle développement de la
société indienne en parallèle des
questions que que vient de poser mon
collègue je le garde
si François Jacques le nez maintenant
oui merci oui votre exposé était très
très complet malgré tout ma question
rejoint celle de Jolly Herriot et quelle
politique en matière de lutte contre le
changement climatique l'Inde mettait en
place cette politique se fait-elle en
coopération avec des partenaires
particuliers ou sur des sujets précis
mais je voudrais aussi savoir quel
regard vous portez sur la coopération
tripartite entre la France les Émirats
arabes unis et l'Inde qui ont été lancé
le 4 février dernier
merci la parole est à jean-norel Guerini
maintenant
merci président eux ce matin en me
levant je vous ai écouté
dans une radio publique
et vous dites que le premier ministre
Monique venait de commettre une faute
politique vous l'avez pas dit comme cela
il y a quelques instants
l'opposant Gandhi du Parlement dans le
prolongement de sa condamnation pour
diffamation envers le Premier ministre
pour
pourriez-vous décliner ce sentiment
cette position
alors qu'il vient seulement d'interjeter
appel et pensez-vous que cette exclusion
aura des incidences sur les élections
générales en 2024 merci
merci la parole à André gatelin
maintenant oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur
d'abord merci pour votre exposé et puis
d'avoir soulevé la question des
chrétiens
d'Inde parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
chrétiens d'Orient dans cette maison et
je me rappelle quand j'ai évoqué cette
question il y a 2 ans les gens ont
découvert que il y avait 72 millions de
chrétiens dont la grande majorité était
catholique et les conditions qui vivent
donc sur la question religieuses c'est
vrai que c'est systématique il y a une
seule exception que je note quand je
vais en Inde c'est le bouddhisme et le
bouddhisme tibétain alors c'est vrai
qu'un travail du dalaï-lama pour montrer
combien le bouddhisme tibétain est lié à
l'hindouisme il y a je pense peut-être
la question du Ladak parce que c'est
effectivement un des éléments
stratégiques et géostratégiques de
l'Inde par rapport à la Chine et comme
la population
tibétaine est importante ça joue un
grand rôle je voulais vous interroger
aussi je viens de terminer la lecture de
Touquet le démocratie de chandlery et
Keynes que je trouve assez formidable
sur le passage despotisme et ce qui est
intéressant dans ce bouquin au-delà
effectivement de ce que vous avez
rappelé vous refusez d'appeler les
libéralisme et vous avez un peu raison
mais la rupture par rapport au à
l'organisation des élections aussi des
systèmes d'équilibre de justice il
ajoute un troisième facteur qui
l'appelle social la mort la mort sociale
et comment d'ailleurs il montre que ce
phénomène est antérieur à l'arrivée de
maudit au pouvoir et que quelque part ce
qu'il faisait dans une société
extrêmement pauvre et inégalitaire il y
avait une notion dignité malgré les
classes et que tout ça est en train
d'exploser de son point de vue au long
cours renforcé par l'attitude du pouvoir
de maudit puis dernier élément un sujet
qui m'intéresse beaucoup de qui est
celui des influences étrangères je suis
toujours je suis beaucoup là dans ce
moment et je suis assez étonné de voir
que cette influence ne passe pas
directement par les ambassades les
autorités ce sont beaucoup les sociétés
oligo
istiques qui vont financer en Europe à
Paris enfin en région parisienne
notamment le premier grand temple le
plus grand temple d'Europe continentale
d'hindouisme traditionnel et j'ai changé
avec certains de ces grands patrons qui
vivent tous à l'étranger qui vivent pas
en Inde mais alors qui mettent
énormément d'argent pour valoriser
l'image ou l'influence en Inde en
particulier en France mais dans le reste
de l'Europe donc voilà si vous avez des
réactions
merci Yannick beaugrenard à la parole
maintenant oui merci président merci
beaucoup monsieur le directeur pour
votre exposé il a l'intérêt de nous
donner beaucoup d'informations et de
nous mettre aussi en appétit de
connaissances et du coup tous les sujets
peuvent pas bien sûr être évoqués il y a
un sujet que sur lequel je souhaiterais
vous questionner sur la condition
féminine en Inde et son évolution merci
Gisèle Jourda maintenant
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur vraiment votre
exposé était passionnant alors moi je
souhaiterais donc poser une question qui
va nous entraîner vers vers le monde de
spatial les étoiles la lune etc puisque
depuis 1967 vous avez parlé c'était très
intéressant du plurilatéralisme je crois
qu'ils ont su s'associer et prendre donc
les différents partenaires depuis 67
avec le RSS ils ont une très grande
politique de développement des lanceurs
à des coûts qui sont donc réduits mais
ils ont aussi beaucoup d'ambition vaut
l'habiter donc
Objectif Lune mais
il ne s'interdisent pas donc de se
préoccuper de mars et dans justement
l'évolution les évolutions géopolitiques
de ce monde et cette course à l'espace
on se rend compte qu'ils sont forts bien
placés et qu'ils ont devancé donc
beaucoup beaucoup de prétendant et
notamment ils nous ont devancé à nous
les Européens par rapport donc à notre
volonté avec l'Agence spatiale
européenne dont c'était un petit
questionnement complémentaire mais qui
je pense est tout à fait d'actualité
dans le monde de controversé que nous
vivons merci les dernières questions qui
sera posée par Rachid theman merci
Monsieur présent ce directeur moi c'est
oui c'est une forme de question parce
que alors l'Inde effectivement est un
futur géant si ce n'est pas déjà on sait
très bien grâce au Pacifique c'est un
île des pièces majeures on sait bien que
c'est une pièce majeure notamment nous
pour nos notre défense même si il faut à
chaque fois donner beaucoup de choses et
donc la question c'est à quel moment ils
seront incapacés de produire de par
eux-mêmes et être finalement des
concurrents d'autres à notre notre
industrie militaire j'ai envie de dire
mais ça voilà après il y a un sujet qui
me tient à cœur c'est que on vous dit
assez peu enfin c'est que cet après-midi
d'extrême droite et que dans n'importe
quelle démocratie européenne ou nous
urgions des pétitions des demandes de
mise au banc de fait de ne pas
transférer un certain nombre d'arbres ou
autre chose et c'est vrai que la
question que alors c'est pour ça moi je
suis passé une question mais en tout cas
comment expliquer ce silence
assourdissant sur une orientation
politique qui est quand même plus que
problématique d'un Premier ministre et
qui le pire c'est que on voit bien que
dans la société si ce n'est que des
discours mais dans la société indienne
il y a des conséquences il y a des morts
il y a des il y a des quand même des
peaux groupes je sais pas comment pas
plus de ça mais tout ça existe et pas
juste des effets de manche c'est une
volonté
d'hégémonique on va dire culturelle
religieuses
qui devient une idéologie qui donc l'un
de va s'aligner dessus et donc ça pose
des problèmes de choix de vie en sachant
que quand on connaît les conditions de
naissance de l'Inde
on n'est pas sans oublier qu'il y a eu
quand même quelques millions de morts au
moment où il y a eu la partition et que
ça entraînait quelques guerres entre
l'Inde ce qui est devenu ensuite le
Pakistan et même le Bangladesh voilà
donc on est quand même aussi un moment
donné un pays très puissant je
l'évoquais qui a sa tête un régime qui
peut poser de réels problèmes sans
parler bien sûr du Cachemire et que
l'Inde extra de la Chine etc enfin tout
ça bon donc voilà donc ma question c'est
plutôt comment envoyer non pas ce que le
premier ministre mais en tout cas
comment ça infuse dans la société est-ce
qu'on peut considérer que c'est juste le
temps d'après ministre ou c'est plus
profond que ça merci merci Rachid et en
fait j'ai une question supplémentaire
par huxory merci président parce que je
pensais que Rachid est mal allait
évoquer le sujet dont je voulais parler
je voulais guérillot tout à l'heure a
rappelé un travail qui avait été
effectué sur l'Inde ensemble racheter
mal je guériais moi-même quelques mois
plus tard nous sommes occupés à
l'Indopacifique et cette fois-ci nous
avons eu la chance de nous déplacer vous
avez montré tout à l'heure une une carte
finalement se superpose assez avec la
carte de française de l'Indo-Pacifique
ce qui est un peu une particularité par
rapport aux autres aux autres pays
le fait que la France aussi se désigne
comme puissance d'équilibre sans qu'on
sache véritablement ce qu'il y a
derrière ces termes et que l'un de vous
l'avez très bien expliqué soit dans le
soit ne prennent pas de position pour
pouvoir continuer à discuter et
commercialiser avec tout le monde est-ce
que vous pensez que ces différents
rapprochements font de l'Inde un
partenaire fiable sur l'Indopacifique et
est-ce qu'il peut selon vous y avoir des
coopérations plus étroites sur ce vaste
territoire avec avec ce pays compte tenu
de ces points communs je vous remercie
voilà merci Monsieur le Directeur vous
avez grosso modo une demi-heure pour
répondre à toutes ces questions mais
vous saurez le faire je n'en doute pas
merci beaucoup toutes ces questions sont
[Musique]
parfaitement je dirais
pertinente et je vais essayer de le dire
répondre le plus précisément possible
sans dépasser l'horaire alors la
question de la population effectivement
nous conduit à celle de la pauvreté et à
celle du changement climatique la
pauvreté c'est une énorme
tâche alors avec et sans accent
circonflexe
parce que c'est quelque chose que l'un
ne cherche en permanence à éviter à
éluder
Annie et puis c'est une énorme tâche
parce qu'il faut s'y collecter quand
même
nous n'avons plus les données
statistiques qui permettent de mesurer
le nombre de pauvres parce que comme je
vous l'ai dit on a plus de
d'insey à l'indienne on a un national
simple qui est l'Insee à l'indienne
qu'on empêche de travailler bon les
statisticiens sont assez courageux pour
faire le travail quand même et puis le
faire passer fuité littéralement et
quand ils ont fait fuiter leur dernier
rapport en 2019 on a vu que pour la
première fois depuis qu'il y a des
statistiques en Inde le pourcentage de
personnes vivant sous le sud de pauvreté
avait augmenté
pour la première fois depuis 1971 que
l'on a ces statistiques on a vu le
nombre de pauvres augmenter en
pourcentage et ce à cause de la pauvreté
rurale
et ça va nous ramener à la question du
changement climatique d'ailleurs on a un
défi majeur l'agriculture indienne est
percutée par la croissance démographique
il faut nourrir de plus en plus de monde
c'est quand même tous les ans 15
millions de bouches en plus à nourrir
vous ajoutez tous les ans 15 millions de
personnes c'est énorme et deuxièmement
et bien on a ces problèmes d'intempéries
de de vagues de chaleur totalement
anormale et la fait 42 degrés au mois de
février à Bombay c'est sans précédent on
a eu ensuite des pluies qui n'étaient
pas du tout de mousson puisque la
mousson c'est pour juillet normalement
et ça ça pose le problème de la de la
ruralité alors c'est paysan ce sont
révoltés vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs
dans votre introduction parce que on l'a
oublié mais les fermiers ont fait un
mouvement de protestation qui a duré
pendant presque deux années contre les
oligarques d'ailleurs parce on voulait
faire de l'agroalimentaire et donner à
Adani et hambani les terres en quelque
sorte donc ils ont réussi à faire
reculer le gouvernement mais il continue
à protester bien sûr parce qu'il
continue la souffrir et il y a pas de
move il y a un grand programme qui avait
été introduit par le précédent
gouvernement
[Musique]
garantie acti et un programme très
important qui donnait à toutes les
familles Rurales victimes de sous-emploi
l'équivalent de 100 jours de salaire
minimum par an
sorte de filet de sécurité si vous
voulez un début de l'État-providence en
quelque sorte une sorte de minimum de
salaire minimum rural bon ce programme a
été démantelé ou en tout cas réduire et
c'est pour quand on a ces chiffres
c'est-à-dire qu'on a vraiment une
puissance une pauvreté de masse qui qui
est nié mais à laquelle il va bien
falloir s'atteler pour
pour notamment lutter contre la
malnutrition ça nous entendrait trop
loin de rentrer dans ces détails mais
vous avez des chiffres là pour le coup
parce que les organismes internationaux
Oxfam en particulier Oxfam fait des
coups de sonde qui permettent d'avoir
des idées du de l'emploi de la
malnutrition on n'a pas de famine on n'a
pas de disette monade de la malnutrition
chronique et que l'on peut mesurer parce
que on voit bien que les corps ne sont
pas ce qu'il devrait être s'ils étaient
nourris comme il fait comme il se doit
vous posez ensuite l'action du
changement climatique et des
partenariats alors oui l'un des
directement frappé l'Asie du Sud en
général et la zone du monde une des
zones du monde qui est le plus direct en
frappé par le changement climatique avec
en particulier
un enjeu énorme c'est la fonte des
glaciers les glaciers maliens auront
perdu un tiers de leur superficie de
leur volume d'ici 2050 ça va avoir un
énorme effet sur tous les fleuves alors
qui d'ailleurs n'irrige pas que l'Asie
du Sud de l'amour d'Aria jusqu'au Mékong
vous allez avoir en passant par l'Indus
le Gange le bras mapoutre vous allez
avoir une réduction du débit de ses
fleuves qui sont à l'origine quand même
de la vie de centaines de millions de
personnes
et donc on a on a là
un enjeu que l'Inde
cherche à gérer on investissant dans le
soleil c'est le solaire sa politique
alternative avec des partenariats
français un total énergie
NJ on crée des des
partenariats alors avec gothamadani pour
la première entreprise ce qui a posé
d'énormes problèmes quand le cours de
bourse de adanis a été fondé le mois
dernier total a commencé à essayer de
retrouver une forme de sérénité qui qui
qui tarde à se concrétiser le choix des
partenaires est compliqué et on n'a pas
forcément les moyens de choisir parce
que de décider parce que le pouvoir
le pouvoir politique et lui-même proche
de certains opérateurs bon le soleil a
beaucoup d'avenir en Inde et c'est la
politique majeure maintenant le charbon
continue d'être la principale source de
production électrique 55% de
l'électricité française pardon indienne
et produite par charbon nous avons
d'ailleurs le mois prochain toute une
journée avec EDF sur la question des
émissions et de la transition
énergétique et l'Inde sera l'honneur et
c'est intéressant de comparer le bilan
une Architec indien par rapport à
d'autres c'est une étude que EDF a mené
de façon comparative et très
très intéressantes
la question qui suit et je m'excuse on
passe forcément du coq à l'âne c'est la
casse alors ces casques continuent à
jouer un rôle très important
surtout pour ce qui est de ce qu'on
appelle les intouchables ce qu'on
appelle encore les intouchables
physique qui est qui est prohibé du fait
de du stigmate le contact est polent
donc on ne touche pas ces gens et on ne
vit pas à côté de ces gens qui sont dans
les villages
cantonné a des hameaux séparés ils ont
leur puits parce qu'ils peuvent pas
venir tirer de l'eau dans le puits du
village c'est un touche habilité là
c'est quand même la grande difficulté de
la société indienne les autres castes
se retrouvent plus ou moins là on a 15%
de la société qui est à part
alors c'est une société qui a quand même
pris cette difficulté à bras le corps
lorsqu'elle a mis en place dès
l'indépendance une politique de
discrimination positive unique en son
genre parce que c'était très courageeux
de dire il y a 15% d'Intouchables on les
recense dans le recensement on veut
savoir combien ils sont et on le réserve
15% des places dans l'éducation 15% des
places dans l'administration 15% des
sièges dans les assemblées élues
aucun pays au monde n'a essayé d'être
aussi volontariste
en termes
et ça a apporté ses fruits on a vu se
développer une forme de classe moyenne
intouchable
qui reste intouchable
le mariage reste une affaire de casse
mais en termes de classe si vous voulez
ils ont pu
s'embourgeoiser
et faire pression pour que il y ait
quand même davantage de
des efforts en faveur de ces catégories
là
cette politique est en train d'être
remise en cause et ça va de pair avec je
dirais la dimension très conservatrice
de du gouvernement actuel on dilue cette
politique alors on la dilue
indirectement à travers les
privatisations c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
pour les intouchables
la planche de salut c'est le secteur
public parce que c'est là que sont les
quotas pour eux dès lors que le secteur
public fond comme neige au soleil et
bien la part qu'ils ont dans ce secteur
public diminuent elles aussi et
aujourd'hui vous avez du coup un retour
en arrière en quelque sorte avec une
perte de de mobilité sociale ascendante
et ça c'est une c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle
Emirats Arabes Unis Inde France oui
c'est très intéressant ce nouveau
dialogue trilatéral au moment même où
d'ailleurs le dialogueil latéral France
Inde Australie reprend puisque après une
période un peu compliquée Anne France
Australie reparle dans l'Indo Pacifique
ensemble et bien l'autre dialogue
trilatéral qui qui lui a pris forme il y
a quelques mois c'est émirat Anne France
c'est à dire que je pense qu'on l'a vu à
travers les cartes pour les deux pays
francéens l'Indo Pacifique va jusque là
va jusqu'aux émirats et donc ça fait
partie d'une géopolitique qu'on partage
la France a des relations très étroites
avec les Émirats notamment du point de
vue militaire
l'Inde a des relations très étroites
avec la France notamment du point de vue
militaire ce triangle il est tiré par la
dimension stratégique communitaire et
par la dimension géopolitique
et donc il a certainement beaucoup
d'avenir
une erreur politique que de disqualifier
Raoul Gandhi oui je pense que
je pense que Narendra maudit a peut-être
fait la première erreur politique de sa
carrière
en prenant le risque de victimiser Raoul
Gandhi
c'est une forme de perte de sang-froid
que ça reflète
on ne se débarrasse pas comme ça d'un
homme qu'on ne pense pas dangereux
franchement le prétexte est très tenu
il a dit tous les maudits sont des
voleurs
on a entendu pire dans la vie politique
et pas qu'on Inde
à cause de ça il est condamné à deux ans
de prison à cause de ça il perd son
siège de député
pourquoi ça suscite une interrogation
était-il si dangereux que ça si les
cidreuse ça c'est que le pouvoir a des
choses à craindre des choses à cacher et
c'est c'est principalement les questions
de relation avec les mieux d'affaires
qui sont qui sont en cause donc je pense
qu'il
a sans doute pas proportionné la
réplique
à l'ampleur du danger
suscitant deux choses un soupçon c'est
qu'il y a des choses à cacher et
deuxièmement
je le répète une victimisation d'un
adversaire c'est pas une bonne chose
c'est pas c'est pas une bonne chose et
du fait c'est maudit qui est en train de
créer son adversaire en fait c'est lui
qui fabrique
son opposant en lui donnant une aura
qu'il n'avait quand même pas pas encore
en tout cas alors là bien sûr la
question la plus importante c'est
jusqu'où est-ce que ça va aller est-ce
qu'il va vraiment être confirmé dans sa
disqualification par la Cour suprême
est-ce qu'il va aller en prison est-ce
qu'il va être empêché de manifester s'il
refait un grand mouvement dans la rue
les étapes qui viennent sont très
importantes on a des élections
régionales dans cinq États qui précèdent
celles qui auront lieu dans un an
exactement
la locaba au Parlement à la chambre
basse du parlement
on va suivre de très près cette cette
chronologie mais ça peut être un
tournant
ça peut être un tournant dans cette
histoire
oui le bouddhisme effectivement est la
religion qu'on ne considère pas comme
exogène en Inde d'ailleurs le Bouddha
est présenté comme le 7e avatar de
vichenot ce que tu de la récupération
plus récente bon
alors c'est lié au fait qu'effectivement
le dalaï-lama a tout fait pour que les
Tibétains s'intègrent à la société
et finalement ils l'ont pas mal réussi
oui
exactement considérant que bon
bouddhisme à douille il y avait un
continuum
ce qui est pas entièrement vrai quand
même parce que les Intouchables qui
cherchent à échapper à l'hindouisme ils
vont où ils vont dans le bouddhisme ils
se convertissent au bouddhisme ceux qui
veulent vraiment sortir de la casse
c'est dans le bouddhisme qui trouve
l'égalité et pour d'une bonne raison le
bouddhisme est égalitaire c'est le seul
la seule religion sur place à ne pas
avoir reconnu la caste et appliquer la
caste maintenant vous évoquez la
question du Ladak et je pense que ça va
être une question assez compliqué en
fait parce que bon le Ladak est
maintenant occupé pour moitié par les
chinois depuis 62
a été privé de son statut d'État c'est
un territoire de l'Union qui a perdu
donc tout autonomie et les ladaki
bouddhistes font de cette
identité un levier pour récupérer de
la substance en quelque sorte dans une
zone aussi sensible stratégiquement
peut-être pas très malin d'avoir en
quelque sorte poussée un groupe à se
montrer plus revendicatif sur le plan
identitaire
on peut craindre aussi la des formes de
répression
je passe à la question concernant le
rôle des grands patrons dans dans le
monde parce que c'est une question très
intéressante
c'est vraiment intéressant le Parti
communiste chinois lui utilise les
branches du parti pour rayonner à
travers le monde où les Instituts
Confucius
l'état indien lui utilise ses relais que
sont les grandes entreprises
d'une part parce que diplomatiquement
ils sont trop petits il y a pas plus de
diplomates indiens que de diplomate
singapourien ils sont 800
alors avec un nombre de diplomates aussi
réduit on peut pas couvrir dans ses
montres toute la planète
oui
Indian friend service life c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont si peu nombreux
c'est le close Shop
c'est vrai d'ailleurs pour toute
l'administration indienne c'est vrai
pour pour
alors du coup
le relais de puissance passe par le
secteur privé qui est de fait très bien
organisé vous avez de très belles
multinationales indiennes à les tata les
bons sont à la manœuvre et vous les
voyez beaucoup en Afrique par exemple
pas que la fait orientale d'ailleurs on
les voit maintenant ta taille d'une
remporter un marché au Sénégal pour les
bus bon c'est tout là toute l'Afrique
qui est leur champ de d'exploration et
puis oui en Occident où ils sont bien
sûr très présents en Grande-Bretagne
alors là vous avez là vous avez une
revanche incroyable de colonisé sur le
colonisateur et quand tata a racheté
Rover et qu'il a racheté Jaguar
ça a fait la une de plusieurs journaux
on va dire pour la bonne pour de bonnes
raisons
maintenant
la diaspora est elle aussi
contaminée par ce virus identitaire et
on a vu à lester Birmingham il y a
quelques semaines des rixes en train
d'où et musulman qui était la réplique
de ce qu'on avait vu en Inde et et Dieu
sait si cette société britannique est
multiculturelle mais là elle atteint les
limites de son multiculturalisme
et c'est un vrai enjeu pour les
États-Unis aussi le Canada vous avez en
plus les Sicks qui sont très très
militants la Grande-Bretagne l'Australie
c'est-à-dire que on se voit on voit
combien le mode est le mode est devenu
globalisé c'est-à-dire que des questions
internes à la Cité indienne se
retrouvent aux quatre coins du monde
évidemment véhiculer par les réseaux
sociaux véhiculer par Internet on se
nourrit au même source on finit par
avoir les mêmes identités et elles sont
conflictuelles donc cette capacité
d'exportation elle a aussi des
inconvénients mais elle est très très
forte alors elle a aussi une dernière
limite les hommes de mains entre
guillemets les proches de maudits qui
ont le plus investi à travers le monde
sont justement ceux qui sont en
difficulté et c'est à nouveau
gothamadani quota Madani a acheté une
énorme mine de charbon en Australie pour
alimenter les assiéries Indiennes il
vient d'acheter le port de Haïfa en
Israël
il est il est le relais incontournable
qui peut être est le maillon faible et
ça nous ramène d'ailleurs à dit parce
que a bien vu qu'il y avait là
trop investir dans une puissance
d'argent qui n'est pas entièrement
propre sur elle
c'est quand même un talon d'Achille
ensuite difficile à gérer
alors une très bonne question concernant
la condition des femmes ensuite parce
que
elle nous ramène d'ailleurs à la
démographie cette question
ce que l'on sait des recensements les
plus récents c'est que ce qu'on appelle
le sex rachio le nombre de femmes pour
1000 hommes
à certains peu augmenté mais reste
bien inférieur on a 900 je vais pas dire
de bêtises mais on doit être à
970 femmes pour 1000 hommes ou 980
femmes pour 1000 hommes bon il manque
des millions de femmes ça veut dire il
manque des millions de femmes à cause de
la
pratique de l'avortement sélectif des
des fœtus féminins
liés à la persistance de la dot parce
que et cette complètement contradictoire
il y a moins de femmes et néanmoins il
faut toujours payer pour les mariés
j'explique j'explique ça aux économistes
qui crochois rationnelles voilà bien
l'exemple que ce n'est pas la rareté qui
fait le prix
parce que il y a pas suffisamment de
femmes pour le nombre d'hommes qu'il y a
néanmoins il faut qu'elle paye pour
pouvoir avoir un époux bon donc vous
avez un énorme problème là de de type
démographique qui qui reflète un
problème social
parce que la fille est un handicap est
un est un fardeau
ensuite alors elle va être et ça c'est
un développement récent assez
préoccupant elle va être en concurrence
sur le marché du travail avec les
garçons et ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
vu le chômage je l'ai pas évoqué ce
point mais il y a un chômage massif il y
a les jeunes urbains sont à 38% au
chômage en Inde
c'est vraiment énorme et les filles en
compétition avec les garçons
s'abstiennent de chercher un emploi de
plus en plus on a un taux d'emploi des
femmes en Inde comparable au
Moyen-Orient on est à 16% c'est très
très bas et donc c'est le reflet aussi
de ce statut de ce statut en retrait que
l'on s'attend à avoir
occupé par par les femmes
oui le spatial est un point fort de ce
pays
c'est tout à fait à nouveau
anthropologique comme explication voilà
un pays qui n'a pas réussi à s'industrer
l'industrie le travail manuel en général
c'est pas leur truc c'est le bramman la
caste supérieure c'est c'est
l'esprit c'est un pur esprit c'est le
cérébral c'est les maths c'est les maths
leur truc ils sont très très forts ils
ont d'ailleurs inventé le zéro comme
vous le savez ils ont des mathématiciens
depuis l'Antiquité
les maths les conduisent à la physique
et à l'astrophysique il y a d'ailleurs
des observateurs astronomiques vous avez
des abstronomiques qui remontent là
aussi au Moyen-âge et qui reste en
activité bref vous avez un tropisme
scientifique qui va aller conduire à
investir dans le Haïti bien sûr dans
tout ce qui est informatique dans tout
ce qui est mal dans tout ce qui est
physique et donc dans le spatial et
autant il peine à construire des chats à
construire des tanks autant ils n'ont
pas de problème pour faire des
satellites pour faire des lanceurs de
satellites pour faire des missiles de
longue portée et pour et pour acquérir
l'arme nucléaire puisque là aussi c'est
de la physique et ils l'ont eu tout seul
ils se leçon est tout seul l'homme leur
bombe la différence des Pakistanais donc
effectivement ça c'est je dirais le
substrat
culturel on retrouve la culture quand
même
mais le rôle de l'État n'est pas
négligeable non plus tout comme nous
avons fait le CNES et que c'est quand
même aussi grâce au CNES que la France
de Sibel réussite dans le spatial l'Inde
a fait l'Indian space resurt
organization
l'État a été le pilote qui a permis ce
genre de réussite et là on a un
partenariat CNES
mais qui est comme vous le dites aussi
incompétiteur parce que ils ont des
lanceurs qui mettent sur orbite
géostationnaire des satellites très
sophistiqués pour beaucoup moins cher
que rien
et c'est pas difficile et donc là vous
avez un énorme sujet ils sont en train
d'effectivement de prendre des parts de
marché surtout que les ratés récents
d'Ariane ne nous aide pas et et là la
collaboration se double de compétition
alors dernière question mais c'est pas
la moindre silence assourdissant et oui
et oui parce que nos partenariats
stratégiques et militaires ne sont
jamais débattus publiquement en France
ou des bâtons des vents d'armes que l'on
fait à l'Arabie saoudite à l'Egypte au
Qatar
comment
non je sais bien mais vous avez pas été
et je pense très important de
précisément se demander
quels sont les enceintes publiques ou la
négociation d'appart de partenariat
aussi important et de vente de
technologie sensible aussi importantes
pour être débattu car on se rend compte
après coup de l'ampleur de du lien qu'on
crée ainsi un lien insécable pour des
décennies mais votre propos
effectivement est différent la question
est celle de savoir si est-ce que
Narendra maudit lorsqu'il aura quitté la
scène
permettra Alain de revenir à la case
départ
alors moi j'ai tendance à dire que le
point de non-retour n'est pas atteint
on a encore une spécivile on a encore
des des démocrates
et des gens qui veulent revenir au
statut quantité mais
chaque jour qui passe permet assez forte
de pénétrer la société et l'État de plus
en plus profondément
il y a de très nombreuses institutions
qui sont maintenant
je dirais acquises assez forts
politiques là et les éradiquer sera très
difficile
c'était d'ailleurs et c'est intéressant
de le dire ce que ce que soulignait déjà
le gouvernement précédent qui voyait ses
forces pénétrer notamment les services
de renseignement et qui se trouvait les
mains liées
ils avaient beau être au pouvoir
politiquement
il ne pouvait pas se reposer sur ce qui
va être sur ce qui aurait dû être un
bras armé de l'État la pénétration de
ces forces idéologiques étant déjà
quasiment achevée donc il y a des
institutions qui sont perdus
par contre il y en a d'autres qui
peuvent être regagner reconquises
et c'est
non seulement bien sûr
[Musique]
au gouvernement qui prendront le la
relève de l'assurer mais avant ça la
société de voter autrement quand elle le
pourra la prochaine fois et c'est là où
je le répète mais l'acte de vote n'est
plus le l'acte libre et et et informé
qu'il était et donc ce biais pèse
énormément
[Musique]
c'est
un problème qu'on rencontre dans
quantité d'autres pays
[Musique]
est-ce que si Erdogan perd le mois
prochain la Turquie redeviendra ce
qu'elle était
c'est un autre sujet et j'en suis bien
d'accord
mais on voit bien combien finalement
les parallèles sont riches
d'enseignement moi ma crainte elle est
plutôt ailleurs ma crainte elle est
plutôt dans le fait que
l'opposition ne pourra pas prendre
facilement le pouvoir et le successeur
de narindramody viendra du même parti
mais n'aura pas la capacité à gagner les
élections qu'il a aujourd'hui il est
populaire donc on vote si son successeur
vient de son parti mais n'est pas
populaire
on votera pas
et donc là on a une autre un autre enjeu
notre défi
que se passe-t-il quand l'un n'est plus
en mesure de garder au moins
cette feuille de vigne qui est le
scrutin
tous les 5 ans
et
c'est pas une hypothèse totalement
farfelue car on voit qui est positionné
pour prendre la suite
amitchad à côté ministre à l'intérieur
yogi
le chef de commande de l'auteur prodige
et ils n'ont pas Laura de narini ils ne
sont pas populaires
donc c'est une question qui est qui est
qui est pertinente et qui nous oblige à
nous projeter dans le temps
je n'hésite pas à chaque fois que je
rencontre un responsable français lui
dire et que faites-vous le jour où yogi
ou amitcha devient prémisse de l'Inde et
là évidemment il y a comme une espèce de
sursaut parce que
on voit bien
que ce ne sera pas le même genre de
personnalité
c'est une dernière question
s'il vous plaît
excusez-moi
alors puissance d'équilibre oui le mot
est quand même
on préfère parler de puissance
d'initiative une puissance la France qui
peut lancer des initiatives et puis
créer les coalitions qui permettent de
les réaliser
c'est plus réaliste
c'est
plus européen
et européenne et la France est une très
bonne idée maintenant que l'Inde soit un
partenaire fiable dans l'Indo Pacifique
c'est une question vraiment difficile
la crainte qu'on a on en parlait
d'ailleurs avec j'ai la chance de
pouvoir travailler avec l'équipe de
Borel et avec Borel lui-même sur ces
questions justement du point de vue de
l'Union européenne la crainte qu'on peut
avoir c'est que là ne soit pas en mesure
de résister à la pression chinoise
voir ne souhaite pas résister à la
pression
on est sur du 1 à 10
en termes de PNB en termes de 1 à 10 et
l'Inde dépend de la Chine pour son
commerce d'une manière considérable
c'est son premier partenaire commercial
elle dépend de la Chine comme nous
dépendons de la Chine pour sa pharmacie
pour tant de produits manufacturés
et deuxièmement elle est maintenant
cernée par des pays qui sont en train de
basculer du côté chinois le Népal Sri
Lanka effectivement l'Afghanistan le
Pakistan c'est fait
Bangladesh madame elle est entourée de
pays qui sont de plus en plus pro
chinois
résister ça veut dire s'affronter ça
veut dire en découdre n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour dire que cette carte est
intéressante vous voyez toutes les
incursions que font les chinois du côté
indien
l'Inde regarde d'ailleurs
l'Inde ni que la Chine lui prend du
territoire
elle fait
l'autre ruche parce qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de faire autrement alors comment
dans l'Indo-Pacifique peut-on du coup
compter sur l'Inde moi je pense que il
faut plutôt voir la dimension maritime
c'est manœuvre conjointe c'est
garde-côtes qui travaillent main dans la
main cette lutte contre la piraterie
internationale enfin l'impératrice
maritime dans cette partie de l'océan
Indien
c'est ça et puis et puis pensez
environnement gestion des océans
lutte contre la surpêche
toutes ces dimensions maritimes me
paraissent les plus porteuses là oui on
peut compter sur l'Inde
en terme géo-politique géostratégique
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
[Musique]